eu sou fascinado pelo evento e estou
sempre lá no site assistindo às
palestras e tem muita coisa que já mudou
a minha vida acho que essa idéia do do
evento é essa troca é que pode fazer uma
diferença e eu fiquei super feliz com o
convite para participar aqui hoje porque
de certa forma isso tem muito a ver com
o que eu acho fazer na música que é
compartilhar as minhas ideias
os meus sentimentos com com esperança de
que isso chegue a outras pessoas e que
faça parte da vida de outras pessoas e
que isso faz uma diferença é que isso é
um líder um senso de pertencimento ao
mundo é que eu que ele sinta fazendo
sendo significativo e de certa forma
acho que todo mundo tem essa ânsia é
puro por fazer uma diferença porque
significa alguma coisa e eu encontrei
essa possibilidade com o meu violão
zinco como a voz e então hoje eu
gostaria de falar sobre duas coisas que
são relevantes
o que eu faço a primeira é a importância
de se fazer o que você gosta o mais
importante do que isso é você gostar do
que você faz
e a segunda é qual é a segunda menos
a segunda é a importância de se praticar
muito o que você se propõe a fazer se
dedicar muito para curitiba
isso faz uns dez anos já vim pra cá para
estudar fazer faculdade de manhã a
faculdade de tarde trabalhava
mas independente disso eu sempre achava
um tempinho pra tocar violão quero que
eu sempre amei fazer
e nesse tempinho que encontrava
novamente ela de madrugada e estava
sempre dedilhando alguma coisa
e numa dessas madrugadas eu comecei a
dedilhar essa harmonia melodia que me
convidou para fazer uma coisa que nunca
tinha feito pra valer que era compor uma
música sempre tocava por pelo prazer de
tocar mas é era esse o envolvimento com
a música não tinha pretensão de ser um
compositor nem nada e aí bom naquela
noite naquela madrugada eu eu sentei
então comecei a escrever algumas linhas
que tem uma letra que vê uma melodia e
gostei do que foi essa o esboço de uma
música e gostei do que saiu gostei tanto
que resolvi passar por algumas pessoas
os meus amigos mais próximos não estava
feliz e olha só o que o que eu fiz né e
aí com o tempo esses amigos passaram
para outros amigos e passava os amigos
dos amigos
eles passaram alguns anos essa música
chegou por um estagiário nação livre e
isso possibilitou toda a minha história
com a isso possibilitou o convite pra
gravar o disco e depois essa música
entrou pra televisão da televisão surgiu
o convite para fazer essa música para a
trilha do filme se eu fosse você 2 que
foi um sucesso de bilheteria depois eu
fui pra isso possibilitou ir para a
coreia do sul fazer um uma turnê pelos
estados unidos para portugal fazer shows
e a música ficou entre as dez mais
tocadas do w gol do japão e isso me
chamou a atenção hoje com certo
distanciamento é daquele momento do meu
momento muito singular muito particular
é o que me chama mais atenção é o fato
de que eu estava fazendo aquilo não com
a intenção de fazer sucesso no japão não
me passava pela idéia nem de nada disso
que eu comentei
ela pela simples vontade de fazer música
de me conectar com aquilo e pelo carinho
de fazer aquilo é a música vai mais ou
menos assim
a vítima amanda salvatierra é de ser uma
só fama papá san andrés eu nem sofre
fácil phay siphan sarney se essa mas na
tenda hora sol era hora da tarde para
datar airão
adaptar a datar a tom é meigo de will i
am
zenon é nós ele faz
baby de sá era assim a ort aí pateiro e
fesf ao af melhor fogo e doure o alho
tinha 'mala' tatára natara então
datará dataram obrigado obrigado e aí de
vez em quando me perguntam mas onde é
que vem a inspiração né
e eu sempre tenho que inventar uma uma
resposta porque eu não sei a resposta
vem de diversos lugares
mas tem uma coisa que eu tenho certeza
que ela está diretamente conectada com
você fazer o que você gosta
isso possibilita essa as entregas de
vocês se descobrir nessa nesse processo
e que é uma coisa equivocada que
acontece é que talvez impede muitos
talentos ou muitas vontades de se
transformarem a muito obrigado
o tal conselho
não só é voltando tem uma coisa que eu
acho que impede essa pós a possibilidade
de se desenvolver alguma coisa que é a
nossa idéia equivocada de que a prática
não na verdade de que o que a gente faz
o trabalho dele é desconexos
o que nos dá prazer né
sabe quando a gente vê uma coisa muito
mal feita que está claramente mal feito
que é claramente um equívoco que é um
descuido não é parece que fica claro o
abismo entre o a pessoa que está fazendo
e oea o que foi feito
isso parece que é justamente o que
transmite é o que traduz essa falta de
conexão com um com que se está fazendo é
como gostar
o que você está do que você está fazendo
e e essa possibilidade de desculpas
tomás molina
essa minha primeira palestra muito
obrigado pela atenção
bom estou falando de dança do
distanciamento é de que existe entre
quem faz e o que está sendo feito
e nesse sentido se não existe essa
conexão esse carinho a gente enche o
mundo de coisa feia de coisa
desnecessária eu acho que o mundo está
carente de pessoas realmente conectados
com o que estão fazendo
e outra coisa que eu acho está
diretamente conectado com essa
possibilidade de criação de criatividade
é praticar muito o que você se dedica a
fazer
não existe outro caminho é lógico que
existe a possibilidade de ter um talento
muito nato que que faz um atalho desse
caminho mas mesmo assim precisa de
trabalho é dedicação e aí de novo tem
uma dicotomia é uma separação equivocada
de que a prática o exercício de alguma
coisa é só um processo para se chegar a
um objetivo é um só eu vou fazer isso
com muita dor agora que isso vai me
possibilitar uma recompensa futuro né
quem o que estou fazendo hoje é
necessário passar por para chegar num
objetivo ea verdade é que não o a
prática é o fim em si
se você está fazendo o que você gosta
isso já é completo você você está
completo no que você está fazendo você
não está esperando um bom resultado
quando tocava no meu quarto eu já estava
satisfeito quando tocava nos bares aqui
em curitiba pra mim já era o fim não
estava fazendo aquilo com o objetivo de
tocar no japão estava fazendo aquilo pra
tocar no bar com a intenção de fazer
aquilo bem feito e eu acho que isso é e
mostrou que essa conexão nos nos mostra
que não existe erro então no processo
que o erro é só a parte do aprendizado a
partir do do caminho
quando o que eu comecei a me dedicar a
aprender a tocar violão é de verdade
mesmo que sente agora eu preciso fazer
alguma coisa bem feita né eu eu eu me
frustra um pouco porque não tinha
habilidade
então eu tentava me frustrava e sentindo
eu nunca você comum ela as pessoas que
eu admiro eu sentir que na verdade eu
tinha um tempo para aprender as coisas
que eu tinha o meu ritmo de aprender e
que era justamente isso
no momento que eu eu consegui decifrar
esse ritmo eu fiquei mais em paz que eu
encontrei essa paciência pra perceber a
de um de um dia para o outro evoluir
tanto em tão legal né isso já está sendo
um processo e isso é mostrou que na
verdade é só o mais importante é ter
resiliência ter persistência no que você
está fazendo
tem uma coisa que é uma história que eu
gosto conta de um amigo meu que ele
seria assim a pessoa menos indicada pra
tocar piano e ele é apaixonado por arte
apaixonado por música e sempre teve
muita vontade de tocar piano
ele só vocês terem uma idéia um bom
pianista é a premissa básica para se
tocar piano é ter dedos longos dedos
finos mãos leves né pra justamente para
ter a sua idéias nesses movimentos
necessários e ele é o posto ele como se
fosse o shrek né aaa a mão gorda o
ajunta grossa o dedo que toca duas
teclas juntos só porque é muito grosso é
o assim o oposto do que seria o ideal
para ser um bom pianista né
mas isso não impediu ele de aprender ele
queria aprender
ele começou a fazer aula e e o professor
dele sim depois de um tempo ele se
impressionou porque ele estava tocando é
óbvio ele não estava e não ia se
transformar num no beethoven no moza do
piano mas não era sua intenção ele
queria só expressar o que era a vontade
dele há a singularidade dele e é isso
que me parece que foi uma
é incrível que o que era inicialmente
uma limitação pra ele é o que é que para
muita gente seria assim você tem mão
grossa você não vai não deve tocar piano
você não deve fazer isso na verdade se
transformou no grande diferencial dele
porque ele ele desenvolveu uma forma
completamente dele de tocar piano que é
linda e que está possibilitando ele
fazer trilhas para cinema pra coisas
maravilhosas retração da carreira dele
como instrumentista que outra pessoa
teria dito não tem muito grossa então é
capixaba vai fazer qualquer outra coisa
e então o à conclusão que eu cheguei com
isso tudo aqui é verdade que não separa
as pessoas que a gente admira dos nossos
ídolos é só o tempo de dedicação essa é
a diferença entre o quanto de dedicação
existiu de uma pessoa para outra
o tempo de dedicação não não de talento
necessariamente e tem uma coisa que
daqui a pouco eu quero tocar mais uma
música para encerrar mas tem uma
situação que gostaria de ler da martha
graham que foi uma dançarina
é incrível que revolucionou a história
da dança moderna porque ela é inquieta
ela queria fazer alguma coisa diferente
ela queria encontrar essa expressão
singular né que ela tinha dentro dela e
por causa disso ela se transformou o que
ela fez a dança foi é que é comparado ao
que picasso fez pra pratt moderno e ela
fala o seguinte que existe uma
vitalidade uma força de vida uma energia
que é produzida através de você em ação
e por que apenas um de vocês e em toda a
história
o universo essa expressão é única
e se você bloquear isso se você não
permite isso
isso nunca vai existir nenhum outro meio
que será perdido
essa música se chama história janela e
ela vai mais ou menos assim
espero que goste chora siga pai que neva
figuera só to de faro figueira espera
lote a leben
espero nos 7 falar para o pim set foi o
irã aceite ou afundar fé pode rá
andré
espero mostrar só que bate o céu e raul
e paris tio sam
robert lee faria espero motivar
hum
espero buscar é chatinha bitten desafio
é vertido
mesmo horas em dias ontem à noite à
sporting
espera-nos cayman então eu acho sem
tátil cilindro é andar diz ele
roth não
espero mostrar
passei
só sei que errei
lira
hum
num
um hum
é a
muito obrigado lote